Does splitting your data into
three separate data sets
sound overly complicated?
Let's look at this in
action in the real world.
Kaggle is a competition platform for
machine learning.
People compete on classification tasks,
and
whoever gets the highest
performance wins.
Here, I'm showing the example of
a scientific competition on data that
relates to the Higgs Boson.
Kaggle also has three data sets,
the training data, the public validation
data set, and a private data set that
is not revealed to the competitors.
Here Kaggle shows you the performance
of the top competitors
when measured on the private test sets.
The green and red arrows show
how different the ranking was
compared to the ranking
on the public set.
Let's look at the rankings.
The top competitors were doing well
on the public validation data and
they remain at the top once
their private data was revealed.
If you go further down the leaderboard,
however, it's a real bloodshed.
Many competitors who thought
they were doing well,
were not doing well at all
in the private data sets.
As a result,
their ranks went down dramatically once
the private data set was revealed.
Why is that?
Maybe they had a good model that did
well in validation just by chance.
What's more likely however, is that
by validating themselves over and
over dozens of times on the validation
set, they ended up over fitting
to the validation set and
failing to generalize.
The top competitors] however,
had good experimental design.
They were not misled into thinking
that they were doing well.
They probably took out some of
the training sets to validate their
algorithm or used more sophisticated
methods like cross validation and
didn't make many decisions based
on the public data set scores.